tu as apporté les capotes quoi toujours
sortir couvert ouais attentats prévus de
baisers commun géré seul 2 pour une
fille marié avec enfants turbulents
la taille les yeux bleus au club à
vendre ça va très bien vous êtes ici
pour un disque et pour un livre on va
commencer par le par le disque c'est pas
un best-of puisque vous avez fait qu'un
seul tube dans votre vie donc c'est
difficile tout faire un buzz top mais
vous avez pris des chansons de dario
moreno il ya des idées des originaux 1
et 7 5
voilà et se dit s'appelle l'enchanteur
et on va écouter à quoi ça ressemble
didier
jeudi
remplie
gbagbo
oui
toujours pour toujours
n'oublie pas
il a bien j'ai fait par mois
je suis jeune
avec
hélas on dit là-bas sénat
et puis il ya bien sûr
depuis des mois
je suis
le plus beau des maçons
l'album centaine de chanteurs derrière
c'est que cette folie derrière cette
fête derrière cette bonne humeur et ses
paillettes il ya un peu de tristesse
quand même oui c'est à dire que il ya un
bouquin qui s'appelle un fond de
tristesse
c'est à dire que c'est une confé jupe
j'ai pas eu la prétention d'écrire un
livre en disant je vais écrire un livre
je suis c'est une confession place je
passe le message en disant qu' au moment
où j'étais dans la lumière avec le
bateau est bien mon ami était en train
de mourir du sida et je cachais ce drame
là à tout le monde
voilà alors c'est un livre
autobiographique effectivement que vous
publié aux éditions sd eux alors vous
raconter qu au début des années 80 vous
approcher la trentaine vivait dans un
dans un studio dans un petit studio rue
de la roquette avec une dénommée
patricia une relation platonique parce
qu'on fait la nuit vous pourrez les bars
et les parcs absolument les parcs qui
sont fermées de nos jours de nos jours
voilà vous courrez aussi les clubs
réservés aux hommes avec des revues de
travestis et puis vous vous rendez
compte en voyant tout ça que c'est ce
que vous voulez faire voulait faire du
spectacle en fait à eric oui je vous
fais un tag je veux faire la fête je
m'éclate et voilà et finalement vous
ressentez en face de saint désir de
faire partie de ce monde là de ce monde
de celle là même ce même désir qui vous
a fait quitter la vie religieuse de
grand séminaire vous avez passé sept ans
oui c'est à dire que je suis sorti du
séminaire parce que je n'étais je
n'arrivais pas à vivre dans le dogme et
dans le et dans ce conte imposer voilà
lorsqu'on impose et donc je suis sorti
un peu à la suite d'une crise de foie si
vous voulez voilà voilà donc vous êtes
là toutes les nuits vous assister à ces
à ces spectacles de travestis un jour un
nouveau barman est engagé un dénommé
antoine
voilà vous flashé sur lui vous parlez de
troubles intense dans le temps il vous
fait peur pourquoi parce qu'ils lui
parce qu'il est fou parce qu'il est
jeune et que moi j'ai quand même 35 ans
lui il est quand même plus jeune que moi
il a cédé 7 ans plus jeune que moi donc
il me fait peur par sa folie parce qu il
aime trop la vie veut l'âme ils veulent
à croquer à pleines dents voilà vous
quittez patricia vous installer avec lui
mais je quitte patricia du jour au
lendemain ce qui est d'ailleurs très dur
parce que patricia j'ai toujours je ne
sais pas ce qu'elle est devenue
mais c'est toujours vous regarde là
peut-être le dit lui un truc là regardez
votre caméra
c'est une des plus c'est une des femmes
de ma vie ouais ouais
patricia je l'aimé je ne vais pas aimer
comme j'aurais dû le lait mais avec le
recul je le ferai certainement autrement
aujourd'hui
vous installez avec ce antoine il perd
son job et là c'est la zone que survive
et oui on se retrouve finalement hébergé
chez emmaüs on n'a plus un rond en poche
et puis voilà
et puis lui commence à travailler à
enghien-les-bains une pizzeria et à
partir de là comme ils travaillent très
bien que c'est une locomotive est bien
et il me paye mes cours de chant et
c'est là que je commence à travailler
ils vous poussent dans la chanson il me
pousser au début vous commencé dans les
maisons de retraite
oui et vous gagnez deux tickets de métro
tout à fait c'était mon cachet je
commence à faire les toutes les maisons
de retraite de la banlieue parisienne
et c'est en faisant les maisons de
retraite et des cabarets la nuit que je
commence à avoir une expérience de scène
peint voilà c'est en allant au charbon
voilà allez vous financent des maquettes
et vous finissez par enregistrer oh mon
bateau qui va là il ya un producteur qui
m'appelle un jour ça cette maquette qui
a été envoyé dans les maisons de disques
il me dit voilà je vous en jeu vous
lancer comme un paquet de lessive
ouais ce qu'il fait d'ailleurs oui c'est
un succès fracassant vous êtes nominé
aux victoires votre clip obtient lion
d'argent à cannes et là le succès du
tour de la tête vous délaissez antoine
il commencé à aller mal que je tout va
très très vite
le producteur créer un personnage et il
me dit faut absolument que le chanteur
éric morena soit exubérant alors moi
comme je suis très timide
à l'époque je suis toujours d'ailleurs
je me cache dans ce personnage et je
n'ai pas la mesure dans l'excès je ne
sais pas le faire
et alors ça prend en télé ça prend des
dimensions papier
de charade et je ne contrôle plus je ne
comprends le plus rien c'est de la folie
vont te pousser à faire de mon client
avec lui tout à fait on est alors prêt
quand je rentrais dans la loge je me
faisais engueuler parce que j'avais soit
dit une connerie ou soit c'était très
dur à l'union et j'avais très mal
finalement à la longue
dans la peau de morena très très mal et
c'est là que vous rencontrez denis le
fameux denis d'une indicible beauté dit
il
premier soir vous flirtez dans les
toilettes du restaurant a déjà gelé
quand même c'est une à une comme ans est
une attraction charnelle et je trahis si
vous voulez l'homme de ma vie quoi là
c'est d'ailleurs toujours le regret que
lorsque j'aurai toujours échange de
numéros de téléphone voulu donner
rendez-vous à minuit le lendemain et là
vous n'arrivez pas à le faire bander
voilà le drame à aix denis il faut le
dire vous parlait toujours de son sexe
lourd que vous soupeser et vous arrivez
pas justement toujours que les gros se
sont pas actives mais je compte
commencer à le croire non mais c'est un
gros tour mon texte je crois que c'est
moi en réalité que je crois que il est
plutôt avec moi parce que je suis un peu
connu mais je ne pense pas qu'il ya
vraiment de l'amour de deux côtés oui je
ne le fait pas bander
ouais c'est évident là commence une
douloureuse vie à 3 donc avec antoine
qui en pleine déprime ce denis dont vous
êtes fous d'amour
vous allez avoir un rôle même temps vous
n'arrivez pas à le quitter
voilà et là denis vous vire et c'est
terrible pour vous condamnez vous vire
visite gelé dans la peau quoi c'est là
que vous parlez du sexe superbes lots et
wii 2 mais je vais vous faire une
confidence série vous l'avez rencontrée
à une époque vous le connaissez de
l'aria 8 août à rien
et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs pour le pour le
posséder daria pour te posséder pour
rouler pour vraiment me mettre le
grappin dessus
le registre est pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire on organise on organise ce mariage
gay qui est quelle histoire est une
histoire de fou et qui fait à deux fois
la bon voila vous faites ce mariage que
tu n'étais pas à l'aise de touvérac gens
tous des braises dans tout et là c'est
le drame ça c'est vraiment le drama
potage
là c'est un peu tu es vraiment rire
antoine découvre qu'il est séropositif
voilà je suis à la fiche avec eux dans
l'opérette de francis lopez à l'époque
tout à fait et antoine commence à
montrer des symptômes
le teint terreux le teint terreux il
commence à avoir mal aux jambes les il
maigrit ne grossit plus et on dit en 18
mois c'est la descente aux enfers
incident a déclaré hu est hélas alors
vous faut dire les choses eric vous êtes
posséder celle que vous avez c'est
antoine qui agonise ans à la maison je
ne peux pas une tour je n'arrivais pas à
quitter d'eux je ne possédais aux jeunes
producteurs ne pas laisser tomber
antoine parce que j'ai toujours le coeur
je l'aimais bien sûr j'aime antoine et
denis 6 ou blessés ma je vais m'aérer
parce que quand on a son copain qui est
en train de mourir et qu'on ne peut rien
faire il faut bien serré et c'est vrai
que minable je vais le soir quand il
quand il prends des cachets pour dormir
quand je lui donne des cachets pour
dormir je vais chez de nuit le soir pour
pour me d'échangé est chargé de ce phare
d'horreur douala
vous vous rachèterait en tous les cas je
m'occupe en 8e spécialisé missiles c'est
à dire acheter à racheter c'est
peut-être un grand mot mais ce match je
fais l'hospitalisation à domicile parce
que il ne supporte qu il a fait trois
heures on a traversé trois hôpitaux la
salpêtrière bichat sainte-anne n'y avait
pas encore nous sommes en 80 ont annoncé
le début l'humour est plus vite
d'ailleurs il part en 18 mois donc à
partir de là il ne supporte plus le
milieu hospitalier
c'est pour ça que le professeur me dis
faut absolument l'hospitaliser chez vous
et lui me demande maison une demande la
maison d'être à la maison et là vous
allez vous occuper les jeunes occupe de
lui je met un terme à un si vous vivez
en carrière sur le côté et je reste
encore je fais encore des prestations
parce que l'agent qui s'occupent de moi
à l'époque me fais encore travailler et
me soutient pas mal mais je n'ai plus
envie j'ai plus envie de faire la fête
j'ai plus envie de mettre un costume à
paillettes
tout n'a plus de sens pour moi ouais
voilà alors voilà lui trouve le repos
mais pas vous vous mettrez 12 ans à vous
en remettre de cette affaire mais j'en
suis pas encore remis vraiment je crois
que je m'en remettrai jamais le livre
m'a et m'a aidé c'est un peu comme une
thérapie mais je n'oublierai jamais je
peux pas on peut pas oublié quelqu'un
qui qui est parti dans de telles
souffrances est en jeu si j'ai écrit ça
je l'écris pour la mémoire d'antoine
mais je l'écris aussi pour les malades
que j'ai rencontrés dans les hôpitaux
pour ce que pour tous ceux qui sont qui
sont partis dans le dans le silence dans
l'anonymat et qui partent encore
aujourd'hui bien sûr j'avais pris
beaucoup de tranquillisants à l'époque
j'en prends toujours
ouais ouais on m'a mis sous prozac ouais
le départ sinon je n'aurais pas tenu le
coup et souvent j'allais loger les quais
de suicide elle est très souvent mais je
n'ai jamais fait de tentative non parce
que il y avait toujours une petite
lumière chose que je comprends pas dans
tout ça c'est que cette cette fois qui
vous avez poussé vers le grand séminaire
parce que j'ai quand même passé sept ans
en séminaire est ce que cette fois vous
a pas aidés à ce moment là mais vous
savez à 18 ans on veut on veut refaire
le monde
je suis un peu entré au séminaire un peu
pour fuir peut-être le milieu petit
bourgeois de ma famille je ne pense pas
que j'avais une grande foi à l'époque
j'ai eu j'ai toujours la foi et c'est
une fois plus du coeur que de la raison
voilà moi je le cas c'est par la foi qui
vous a aidé c'est toute la foi m'a aidé
mais pas totalement
ouais elle leur est culpabilisé aussi
elle m'a culpabiliser je me dis qu'il va
vous parler quand vous parlez je suis de
l'autre que vous aviez on d'aller voir
l'autre ça c'est un raisonnement très
catho je trouve assez très catholique
monsieur 14 je peux pas en dire mais
c'est pas la foi qui ont des origines
c'est pas la foi qui est en cause c'est
pas moi c'est la morale c'est la broye
la morale
c'est publié chez les ch d
le plus beau des maçons
cette chanson ça me rappelle dan minuit
c'est tout à fait l'école de bernie
n'goyisa avec un ami que nous avions
entre m'inquiéter il vous rousies bien
sûr que j'aimais beaucoup
voilà